Bad Bosses create more businesses than
entrepreneurs will ever create you won't
lose a recruiter if you're dedicated to
get them achieving their personal goals
their professional goals are irrelevant
unless they're achieving their personal
goals welcome back to another episode of
the recruitment mentors podcast my name
is heam Aus and on this week's episode I
was joined by the co-founders of X
recruiter deand and Blake they're based
out of Brisbane Australia and they're on
a mission to build a worldwide community
of what they like to call the next
generation of recruiters who are
succeeding on their own terms so Blake
for yourself obviously you you started
your own recruitment business Vendo
which is still going and you've been
doing that for six years deand um
yourself you started your own
recruitment business called blender
deployment and again you've been doing
that for 5 years both Declan and Blake
built their own recruitment businesses
and as we all know there's a ton of
challenges that come with that journey
and they thought there was a better way
so they've been building ex recruiter
over the last 12 to 18 months and
they've now launched 45 different
recruitment Brands they're all about
making it as easy as possible for
amazing recruiters to go out on their
own not have to worry about all of the
business stuff so they can focus on what
they're great at which is recruitment
they have their own podcast called
Confessions of a recruiter that I'd
recommend checking out and I really
enjoyed our conversation and really
broke down what they feel they have to
offer recruiters that are maybe
considering starting out on their own
but really fearful of what that means
what that takes and the platform that
they're building to make that as easy as
possible what should I be really leaning
into that could hopefully result in
keeping my my best performance well mate
I think um Blake's a perfect example of
this so let's get into this week's
episode denin Blake welcome to the pods
thanks mate thanks for having us thanks
for having us all the way from little
old
Australia there we go yeah no been been
looking forward to this obviously Declan
I've been speaking to you um
mostly obviously Blake we're going to
get to know each other in in this
podcast but I've really enjoyed seeing
how you've approached building ex
recruiter um I think the way that you've
marketed your proposition the way that
you've gone about your business I've
I've really respected also you have your
own podcast confession of recruit as
well so I've really um enjoyed uh seeing
those so yeah it was really to to get
you both on the the Pod to talk about
this this journey that you've been on
with X recruiter um so I guess just to
give people some immediate context that
might be helpful and then feel free to
to jump in here but so Blake for
yourself obviously you you started your
own recruitment business with Endo which
is still going and you've been doing
that for six years and then deand um
yourself you started your own
recruitment business called Blended
employment and again you've been doing
that for 5 years so you know you guys
have been in the trenches of having your
own recruitment business still
are and this is what I really like
because I'm assuming then you know how
you built ex recruiter you built it from
a perspective of what you would have
loved to have yourselves right um so now
you know the the short uh context on X
recruiter is you enable uh recruiters to
launch their own recruitment business
and we're going to go into to exactly
how you do that and how you've
approached that proposition um so that's
just some immediate context for everyone
listening but I guess where we always
like to to start and I'm sure this is
something that both of you have really
thought uh you know long and hard about
when partnering with recruits to start
their own businesses So Def I'm going to
come to you uh first but I'd love to
hear your take on what you believe are
the common characteristics and traits of
a highly successful recruiter in in
today's market what what do you believe
those are M I think people that can lead
themselves someone that can show up no
matter what be consistent um and then
always you know it sounds a bit bit lame
but like have that hustle mentality um
be willing to graft I think that's what
everyone says in the in the UK um but
yeah just really that that want to rip
in um they can create belief in
themselves they enjoy the winds um and
and not shy away from from doing the
work you know it's like you start a
business there's a big blue ocean of
opportunity um but the ones of the
successful are really nail down and what
they're good at and focus on that and
then that's where the success comes the
opposite is is trying to be everything
to everyone so that would be a few of
the common traits that that I would
think make successful recruiters outside
of um everyone else when jumping into
business love that Blake what have you
got to add from your
take yeah I I think um Dean's done
pretty well there I I'd probably just
add perseverance uh it's quite easy to
get in your own head uh when you're a
new business own owner or when you're a
new recruiter so uh just being able to
step outside from the voice in your head
and and just kind of stick to the basics
and just follow the basics through um
you should have no issues I mean it
sounds easi well it sounds like it's
pretty easy but it's actually uh quite
tough for a lot of people to uh not
listen to The Voice in their head and
just stick to what they know and stick
to the process so as long as as long as
you've got a high work ethic and and you
find reasons to to pick up the phone and
find reasons to speak to people and you
don't listen to The Voice in your head
you should be good to go
love that well let let's get straight
into it Blake I'd love to hear your take
on like the story around the experiences
and challenges that you had as a
business owner that started to you know
plant the seeds of you know launching a
proposition and offer a service like ex
recruiter what were some of the things
that you personally faced when building
vendito that made you think actually you
know ex- recruiter and and this
proposition and and uh um you know
service you de built together over the
last year is something that I think
people would really benefit from like
what were some of the things that showed
up when you were on that Journey
yourself yeah so there's a few things
that I that I wish I did that I didn't
do when I started
vendido one of those things was um
taking like systems and processes more
seriously when you start your own agency
because you're a oneman band you can cut
as many corners as you want because you
know what's going on in your business
and that's what I did when I started
Vendo you know I'd have a database I
think I used bullhorn at the
time I'd be reaching out to clients I'd
make a placement I'd just invoice it out
I wouldn't log it in the database you'd
never know I'd make a placement if if
someone external you know audited my
business from a CRM standpoint because
ultimately your CRM is the value of your
business um to a degree and they saw no
candidate nodes no calls no placements
nothing doing um then they'd go this
isn't a business at all right so um I I
really wish I probably took the the
processes and systems and doing the
right thing um early on U I think that
would have made my business scale and
growth far quicker um so one thing that
we teach our recruiters that join X
recruiter is just because you're a
oneman band don't act like it you need
to act like an employee that you would
pay so if you're sitting there making
zero calls and you're just sending out a
few DMS on LinkedIn and you're expecting
to be paid $300,000 a year would you
from your own Billings and Etc you know
would you pay a recruiter would you pay
someone else to sit there and send out a
few DMS and expect to make 300 Grand a
year and you have to pay them and most
of the time it's like oh I wouldn't pay
myself for the work that I'm doing in my
own business why should I um why should
I pay you know what I'm earning at the
moment so um hopefully that made sense
there's a bit of a tongue twister there
but um ultimately it's it's about being
the person that you you want to employ
uh from day one rather than just um
rather than just kind of cutting corners
and and so forth so that's what I did
when I started vendido and I wish I
didn't do that I'd probably be far
better off and I'd be able to retain
staff and train them far easier in the
outset um another big thing is uh
worrying about headcount probably a
quick
um uh a quick kind of Pitfall that I had
when I was new in business was thinking
that my business was valued at how many
head heads I had in the seat and I hired
like 10 recruiters 12 Recruiters in like
the first six months and I was like
booah I'm killing it I've got 12
recruiters working for me and that was
far from the case it was chaotic it was
crazy I was making no money I was super
stressed and then had to swallow the
pill so to speak and and get rid of
those ego statistics and come straight
Back to Basics and just focus on just
doing a good job as individuals um so
you know that's one of the things that
we teach our guys is anyone that joins X
recruiter we've made heaps of mistakes
um mistakes that you don't think about
when you first start business um you
know when you first start business
you're like oh laptop and an internet
and I'll be good to go and you know how
hard could it be and whilst there's an
element of you know it you don't need a
huge amount of resources to get started
um there's a lot of um guidance and
mentorship and and pitfalls and blind
spots that you run into as you're naive
and you've never done it before so um
with exec we we've put a big focus on
mentorship guidance and walking um
recruiters through the Journey of that
business owner mindset that um takes a
long time for people to realize
especially if they've got no one to
bounce ideas off to go oh hey I am on I
am not on the right track this is the
track I'm meant to be on and kind of get
them back on track so that's probably
one of the things that I think is a huge
value ad and an
intangible uh value that that ex
recruiter
provides I really like the I'm I'm a
huge advocate for systems and processes
I speak to a lot of people about that I
really like how I I really agree on just
because you're a onep person business
doesn't mean that yeah like you should
just not like treat your processes and
how you'd approach things just really
complacently because it's just you cuz I
just don't think that regardless if you
have aspirations to grow or not I think
if you take your systems and processes
serious to start whenever you do hire
maybe a virtual assistant or like just
someone in the future you're going to
thank yourself for it and also it is
very surprising how many recruiters
can't actually don't have documented how
they do what they do and that's just
like really um useful so I really like
that point I
guess Declan would you would you mind
you shared with me right so in this past
year and let me know if any of this is
wrong but in the past year you've uh
launched 20 recruit businesses via X
recruiter is that right so so would you
would you mind just sharing with us
obviously Blake told us a bit about some
of the things that you know you've built
X recruiter around that he wish he did
um we're going to go more into that but
would you mind just sharing you know
like the core proposition what x
recruiter is like how how do you help uh
recruiters exactly and then let's let's
dig into this year what we've learned
what we've seen um and all that good
stuff yeah yeah so one of the big things
that's happened um even just continuing
on probably another third pillar is the
The Branding and image of the the
agencies that we help create so that
would be one thing that's definitely
overlooked with a lot of recruiters
because you're trying to skimp out on
not only your resources systems
procedures but also your branding and
how you present online so that's one of
the big emphasis that we do making sure
that our recruiters look who they are
they don't look like a firsttime
business owner there's a bit of a
running joke that internally they look
like they look better than every agency
they're leaving so that's Paramount for
us um the way their email signature
comes across their LinkedIn Banner their
website all that stuff ties in so that's
why it's super important um on that
front and probably the biggest thing um
that we've learned throughout the years
or throughout this year um would be the
way having luck early not luck but I
don't know if it's the excitement or the
success quickly and then realizing what
it takes to back it up and not and
knowing that it's not it doesn't just
last forever so like there's been a lot
of um quick successes and you know
they've and then the foot comes off the
gas a bit and then for a month they're
like oh I thought it was just going
to continue forever um so that was
probably one of the big learning
experiences that
yeah I really like that deck and that's
so true because I think you pee like
when you post that post on LinkedIn
right new job start my own business
you're buzzing right everyone's like
yeah Blake amazing congrats blah blah
blah everyone's hyping you up
three months later when you're in the
trenches of you know having your first
deal not come through um and someone
still hasn't paid you your first invoice
because it's 60 days late you're like
hell I'm I'm quite far away from
you know all this dopamine I had when I
let everyone now I'm starting a new
business and everyone is Hing me arits
you're completely right at the beginning
I wrote down like um an idea for a post
because I don't know if you've seen this
but I definitely find that you can tell
when someone just launched a recruitment
business because they're way more active
on LinkedIn they're shouting about it
you know they're they're doing all of
that and why is that it's because the
excitement is higher but and then
whatever the time period is as you guys
all know you know like doing things for
five years six years having your
business it's hard so it's like
okay you know you can ride this wave
enjoy it but then when push comes to
shove when things get hard it's like
okay yeah like it's all on my shoulders
like it's it's down to you right so yeah
I definitely yeah I can definitely see
I'm I'm not surprised that you said that
that's a really good point yeah and
because I didn't have a great start in
in my business like highwell H people
Limitless TRG they they've all build
more in their first 90 days than I did
in my first 12 months and like obviously
you know that's the whole you know
that's what we envisioned for ex-
recruiter to do to launch do do what
took us three or four years do that in
the first 12 months like that's the
reason why the model exists but um yeah
I never had those quick wins so it was
like two years of just slugging it out
getting rejected shitty everything
shitty brand all that all that stuff and
you're plugging away and banging out
videos but I suppose the one thing and
we've even seen it in our networks just
me and Blake were the ones that just
kept showing up year after year week
after week and I suppose that's the
reason why we ended up as as business
partners we never we had competing
agencies so we never even thought about
um joining agencies together or anything
like that so it's um yeah it's pretty
exciting now how it all comes out in the
wash so we so with' ex- recruited then
like just give us the the details of how
this works and so I'm I'm a recruiter
listening to this I'm maybe have you
know aspirations to have my own uh
business I'm you know really concerned
and worried about starting my own
business because I don't know how all
the business stuff works whether that be
setting up my uh company account I've
never done marketing I don't know how a
p&l works I don't know you know how how
do I make sure that my business is
profitable whatever you know the the
things that I'm concerned about like
just just um share us like the core
proposition of EX recruiter like how it
works yeah so if you're a recruiter
listening to this and and you're going
to have lots of questions and
insecurities and and um questions um the
first step is to just reach out to us
we've got like a four-step process that
we take recruiters through to determine
whether or not they should even start a
recruitment agency because you you'll
get a lot of people that um you know
some people are in the industry for like
6 months and they're like dude I'm way
better than my boss I'm going to go
start my own agency like now
and you know some people are in at 10
years and they're like oh geez I think I
need a little bit more experience before
I go do this so every everybody's
journey is really different so I guess
the first step would be to have a chat
to us and we'll go through the four-step
process to make sure that one are you in
a good financial position to start an
agency it's important to live below your
means reduce your debt not have lots of
expenses because you will have a period
of no income so how long how how long
can you last without that income so
we'll go through all these like kind of
light style personal professional type
of things to make sure you're set up but
if you you do make it through and we
think we're we're all a good fit and
we're all going to be successful the
first thing we do is uh set you up with
our accountant set up your business um
set up all your business accounts bank
accounts uh you meet out on boarding and
branding Specialists start developing
your logo your brand internal legal get
your terms of business done up um the
the reason why ex recruiters is kind of
special is when when you're an indep
dependent recruitment agency owner or
you know you're starting out on your own
you've got to go seek all these external
resources and generally because you're a
onean band you get you get you know
taken advantage of to a degree and you
pay a premium because you're not a big
enough fish to to Warrant a discount so
all these oneman bands pay a premium for
their resources for their tools for
marketing accounts admin all that kind
of stuff so we've got basically an
internal team that will help you out
with your marketing your branding your
technology your accounts invoicing
chasing up legal debts if you've got a
client that's like ah I'm not paying I
didn't sign the terms haha I tricked you
um you know what do you do then when
you're a one man ban and you've got no
resources or support behind you you got
you got to scratch your head and just
trust your gut and just figure it out
whereas with exr you're able to like
call ex recruit up and go hey I've got a
client at the moment I've sent them
terms they're not paying my invoice what
what should I do here and you've got
like this internal support system to
make sure that one we can set you up and
two we can keep your business running
just as you do right now when you're
running your own desk at your current
agency it's no different we do exactly
what your current agency does but
instead it's your brand your face on the
door um and we hold your hand and walk
you through every step of the process we
get two types of recruiters like one
type of recruiter goes I want to be a
business owner I want to get a better
commercial Acumen I want to learn this
stuff can you like walk me through how
to reconcile my accounts why do we do it
this way how do we submit um to get like
GS well I'm not sure what you guys call
it vat is it vat GST yeah yeah how how
to get that back and like all these kind
of business things that they want to
learn and and um upskill in so we can
either sit down with them and and walk
them through how everything works but
the other half just go man I don't give
a about any of that I just want to
make sure that someone's supporting me
they're going to make sure everything is
always in order so I can just focus on
billing because that's all I care about
so you get really two types of
recruiters one that you know want want
to be handheld and and learn everything
and others don't really care they just
they just want to know if they've got a
good brand and we've we're sorting them
out that they're going to be in good
shape and um so it's it's pretty
interesting to speak to different types
of recruiters needing different things
out of their
business and then and then Deon how's it
work because the most people that I
speak to the main reservation as to like
why I might consider partnering with X
recruit to launch my recruitment
business is that in the long term I'm
going to feel you're going to become how
would I how would I describe it like at
the at the beginning you might be like
yeah they've you know massively helped
me start all these things but then as
time goes on as I earn more money I
might feel like that you're taking a
larger chunk than you deserve right so I
think a lot of people concerned about
are X recruiter going to earn a big
chunk of my business are they going to
take a big chunk of you know my Billings
like how as the final bit how does that
work beckin because I think that's also
important and that's often what people
are concerned about yeah yeah and it's
interesting the further it goes on the
more research recruiters do the more
they find it's it's um you know you just
got to understand about business but
yeah that's one of the big objections is
everyone thinks if they send 100% of
their own invoice they make 100% profit
margin in their business like we all
know um but x- recruiter works on having
a baseline net profit in your business
so it works on a sliding scale so the
more you Bill the less you pay um
essentially because you're and you're
you're released of zero Supply contracts
so EXT recruiter hold Supply contracts
you get the benefit of Premium resources
without zero commitment to any of them
so you can you know it's a fluctuating
um seat your usage depends on you know
whatever you want to use um and then
it's 25 to 10% changing by 5% per
500,000 um in Billings to add to that
and to answer your question more
directly around you know what if in like
three or four years time the the um the
balance is shifted you know ex recruit
is taking more money and we're not
giving the value from the start I think
I think that's a really valid question
just to answer that I mean if someone
wants to leave they can leave at any
time uh and they can go get their own
resources and back office so there's no
commitment we don't take a percentage of
someone's business um they own their
business 100% this is like a really
unflattering way to to sell X recruiter
but we're just a resource provider
ultimately we're we we're a service
provider to your agency if you decide
you want to go get a different service
you can we've thought about what it
looks like if you got five recr 10
recruiters how scalable is it when
you're building your agency to justify
giving X recruiter a percentage of your
income we um we haven't got there yet I
mean vendido we have 10 Recruiters in
our agency through ex recruiter and it
works for us my own agency so we kind of
walk the walk in that regard but in four
years time if you feel that you're not
getting the value and you want to take
everything in house you just take
everything in house we we'll wear that
as a badge of honor because we've been
able to get a recruiter to starting
their own agency to scaling it to
growing it to the point where they don't
need us anymore so that's probably
something to celebrate rather than
something to
fear yeah no for sure and I appreciate
you sharing that so let like I'm glad
hopefully people understand understand
that right and I think that's often you
know what people just want to know and
understand so Dean let me come to you on
this like I think what where you guys
can now you know offer a really unique
perspective is you've worked with 20
individual people individual different
businesses and you've seen you know what
people have done well what people maybe
um you know struggled with so I'm really
Keen to sort of tap into that
perspective uh for people listening so
they can learn from that so you shared
with me you know I asked you to share
with me some of your best success
stories so far so some of the ones that
you shared with me again feel free to
correct me but you shared with me that
company called H people did uh
297 K worth of fees I don't know if that
was in like a year period I don't know
but um then had a company called Harwell
that did 200 Grand in 90 days you had a
recruit uh group did 126k in 90 days
Limitless did 116k in seven weeks so you
know looking at these businesses I guess
first thing that I'd love to get your
thoughts on Dean is like you know what
what did these companies do really well
to to achieve those sorts of figures
that quickly because often times people
have covenants you know people have a
restrictive period where they can't just
pick up the phone to their clients where
it could be easy money they've got
relationships with there so these people
have to lean into something that maybe
they haven't had to do for a while which
is client acquisition which is having to
go out there win business so what do you
think you know looking at from that
perspective what do you think these
people have done really well what do
those first 90 days look like for these
people and how how do they approach it
to get those sorts of outcomes yeah
awesome so that those results are all
within the 90 days besides Lisa was 7
weeks um oh nice yeah yeah so H people
they also out of that 297 they're a temp
agency so they do like Contracting for
warehouse and Logistics and they got 80
temps out within that time as well so
plus a mix of perm so pretty successful
for two guys in in their first 90 days
the the big thing that they do well is
the across all of those companies is the
the daily activities they took exactly
what they do at a normal recruitment
agency they mapped their Market they
knew what competitors who who their
competitors of their clients were that
they weren't dealing with and they they
built a cold desk from scratch so you
know in regards to automation lead
generation um emails campaigns LinkedIn
text messages like we're we're pretty
big on that type of stuff it helps build
a cold Dash really quick if you map your
data correctly um so that's something
consistent that all of those um people
did and they also just did the daily
habits every day of a successful
recruiter they're already high
performing Recruiters in their previous
agency um so they just took what they
did well so that's you know having kpis
kept themselves accountable across
meetings candidate submissions
interviews deal flow pipeline um and
then just repeated it across the
companies that they didn't work with
within their
industry and did
these like ju just curious like the
these people I know you said they were
high performing but often times if
you're a high performer you climb the
ranks in your recruitment business
typically so you might find yourself
managing a team leading a team and often
times that involves being hands offed
so obviously it's not always the case
but were these people you know before
they started working with you guys were
they in a position where they hadn't
build for a while or they would like you
know dip in and out of it every now and
again because they're leading their team
like yeah were were their hands off
before they then just you know dug
straight into it yeah Sam so Sam and
Jory they're from H people Sam was
pretty much hands off I think he had
three people he was managing um Jory was
a little bit more Hands-On but he had
two people that he was managing they had
a team of five that they built up um so
yeah they they got pretty far into their
business um and they decided to you know
do it for themselves um Fraser had two
people reporting to him um so he went
back to to working for himself he's from
the recruit group um Adam I think from
Harwell he was one of the directors he
was getting to the point I think he had
a candidate resource for six months so
yeah they were um there was only I think
Harvey was the only one that that wasn't
Direct managing someone out of them oh
and Lisa was a so she' she'd always she
had 18 month recruitment
experience yeah yeah fair enough because
that that can often be sometimes like a
concern or like a limiting belief of
like can I can I still do deals you know
if you haven't done it for a while yeah
yeah 100% or even doing um building up a
temp desk and being like the golden
handcuffs how am I ever going to get rid
of this contract book or it's owning me
GP every single month and I'm getting
paid on it like how do I actually take
that next step I'll always be giving up
the the prior month or the prior quarter
so you know you got to come to terms
with
that so there there's some there's some
of the things that have gone well Blake
what have
you what have you found yourself maybe
you and Dean run into um consistently or
quite often when it comes to you know
the challenges that these people like
face that maybe you least expected it
could be like a you know mindset
challenge limitting beliefs it could be
I don't know just anything that you run
into that you found people have to
wrestle with or have struggled with um
since going from an emplo employee
mindset to a business owner mindset what
have you found that people have often
struggled with that maybe they least
expected uh probably what Dean mentioned
earlier in the call around like I call
it the three month slump where you're
ripping in for the first two months and
then the third month is always you
the
bed
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
call it the three Monon slump so you're
like you know they're ripping in for
eight weeks they've got all the
adrenaline and um they're they're
crushing it and then they think that
this is freaking easy and then they go
through this slump period where they're
like Wow have I just made a really bad
decision here I've pulled up a donut or
close to a donut or it's way less than
than I got for the for the first two
months um and you know sometimes it
happens in the second month sometimes it
happens in the fourth month but
generally you know around the third
month area um they let their foot off
the gas and then they start getting
creative and cute with being a business
owner oh I'm going to start a podcast
I'm going to start doing lots of
LinkedIn posts I'm going to go to
networking events and whilst they all
are really valuable things to do in
recruitment when you're in your first
like 6 12 months of starting your
business the only thing you can really
think about is just getting money in the
door and sticking to General recruitment
activities the basics uh and so
sometimes it's just it's really just
like having a chat to someone and
they're going oh man I've got no jobs
I'm like okay how how much prospecting
are you doing like oh none okay do you
think you should you know get on the
phones yeah I know I should but I'm just
not like
well uh okay well let's just get on the
phon say let's and like oh look I'm just
finding it hard to focus blah blah blah
there's so many things happening and
it's kind of like this that the wool
gets pulled from over their eyes and
they're no longer just turning up and
and focusing on one thing at their desk
well they still technically can but they
get distracted with so many new found
blue ocean opportunities well I could do
this now I could do that now so it's
just trying to keep people focused and
and engaged and and focused on what
matters and and not getting them
drifting off too far because when you
start drifting off too far it you lose
your results then with lower results you
get disheartened then you get
disheartened and it's like this bad
cycle so half the game's a bit sometimes
we feel like we're pts you know pumping
them up keeping them accountable um but
you know they get through that little SL
and then they're just you know they're
firing on all cylinders and they're good
to
go the three month
lump it happened to me mate my my even
when I started in recruitment I think my
first month was like 29k then 10K and
then like 38k and then six yeah and then
six yeah coming into
Christmas so yeah yeah
it's that is really interesting to say
that because yeah I'm really not
surprised that cuz like you said the
wall the wall is then pulled from their
eyes and they're like right I I
literally have to show up and and do
this core activities every single
day like Blake I'm I'm just curious just
to make this really straightforward for
people because I'm sure you've found
yourself repeating yourself consistently
when someone is in that three month
slump you're having those conversations
of like okay well you know tell me a bit
about what you're doing how you're
approaching things like what what do you
believe are those core activities and
know we getting granular here but like
what what are the core activities that
all all I need to focus on is showing up
every day and doing them and
being disciplined with it and just
focusing on that rather than like you
said getting distracted with maybe these
big Grand ideas now you're a business
owner that basically take you away from
doing the thing you know um what what
would you define as the thing that you
need to do every single day that you've
encouraged people to do yeah how many
good conversations have you had with the
client today a prospective client an
existing client a new client whatever
usually it's like oh none like okay well
can you do deals without speaking to
clients no okay so should you be
speaking to clients every single day yes
okay let's do that what clients have you
got in your database I've got a brand
spanking new database I've got 12 people
in here cool have you spoken to all 12
of these people this week no okay let's
do that next who are the competitors of
these 12 people uh let's build this out
to 36 people call those 24 people and
introduce yourself and let them know
that I do deals I've got a client this
is my client these 12 clients I send
them great candidates would you like me
to send you great candidates too um and
then once you've spoken to those 24
build out for 48 and then just keep
calling and and stringing out your
network mapping it out and and stay on
the phone I know sometimes people get a
little bit awkward like oh hey you know
I'm I'm a new agency owner and I'm
calling you about you know some
candidates that I don't have yet but I'm
just trying to build a relation ship so
hopefully one day I can work your live
jobs like sometimes I feel a little bit
awkward with this approach when they
don't have anything backing them and
there's kind of like a little bit of an
insecurity there but um it's just it's
just about knowing that you've got an
amazing value ad that you can give to
businesses if they give you a shot so um
just tell them like hey I'm a new
business owner I'm looking for some new
clients um I'm really Keen to work with
just a select few companies over the
next 3 to 6 months I'd love for you to
be one of them and here here's my
details I can find your candidates right
now I can keep you updated when good
candidates come in the market what do
you generally look for cool all right
what's your what's your email address
Sweet let's be in touch call them again
in four weeks hey no candidates at the
moment haven't found anyone in inside of
what you generally look for but just
sort I'd give you a buzz let you know I
haven't forgotten about you and uh I'll
chat to you again in four weeks and then
just keep having conversations and don't
stop doing that until you do deals a
very quick word on our sponsors Vin
Cherry before we get back into the
episode as they have a special winter
offer that I want to make you all aware
of this offer is only available until
the 20th of December so if you like the
sound of this then make sure you get
taking action before then if you are not
happy with your current CRM don't settle
switch to Viner for zero implementation
fees plus you'll get a gift of your
choice video interviews 5003 minutes per
month which is normally £99 per month
time sheet processing at £1 per worker
which is normally £5 per worker per
month or recruitment agency website
first 3 months free which is typically
normally between
£735 to £ 3,900 depending on the chosen
package if you also mention that you
listen to the podcast you'll also get an
additional three months as a listener of
this podcast so if you want to make the
most of this offer you've got until the
20th of December to get all of those
benefits check out the link in the show
notes go to Vin
Cherry well the thing I don't know if
you found this
but something that is really
underutilized I found from a recruitment
perspective if you're partnering with
people that are typically High
performers what they should have a track
record so although you know they are a
new business owner what they will have
should have is a track record of like
what they've done
you know previously so don't know that's
like that's that's evidence that's
that's something yes I can I'm a new
business owner but I've got all this
evidence over here that this is what
I've done for these types of companies
for these types of people in in this
industry the X number of years so like
surely you know High valuable
conversations but then also you can
utilize your track record in that way
which I find often recruiters don't do
often than us 100% and a good um a good
uh practice or way you can do that is
actually set up a table so we give all
our recruiters we call it like how to
sell sell with stories and you actually
divide it up in a table who what where
when why and how um you know have the
the company the time the person's name
what situation they were in beforehand
what objection they had until they
realized for that's a result and if you
can be really specific when you're
talking to say hey this is Blake
Thompson from vendido um in 2000 January
2022 he thought our fees were too high
until he realized that the ROI on
getting a really good recruiter in his
agency was XYZ that person then brought
in 400k of new business that Blake had
zero relationships with so I'd love to
you know that's the so just repeating
those stories and using them as ammo in
the past and every time you get an
objection you just add them to your list
so when you're going through Discovery
calls maybe reflective or cost of in
action questions you can Loop them in um
or maybe on a BD call oh you remind me
of Jamie at XYZ and you know just having
these little processes in that you know
we bring in the external Consultants
like the best people we can find in the
industry not only because of the podcast
but just from relationships or actually
just paying for them to come in and give
that information to recruiters because
you're you're on your own me and Blake
wouldn't even look at getting a website
B worth more than $5,000 before ex
recruiter let alone getting a consultant
to come in and pay him three grand a
month but because there's a inclusive
Network you can warrant the the use of
it and it can be shared across all just
like every other resources so you know
training technology are two of the
biggest factors that's that's going to
um empower the network yeah no yeah I
love that um framework so C curious then
Dean like because I'm sure this is
something that you and Blake have both
continue to refine during this sort of
year Journey OB so you mentioned the
four-step
process what I know everyone's like on
their own journey and different and
there might be some people out of like
what you figured out works really well
but what what have you found to be like
the sweet spot from your perspective in
terms of like people that have got X
number of life experience X number of
recruitment experience they've got X
like track record like what have you
found to be like The Sweet Spot of
someone that you'd be very confident
with the right mindset with the other
things that they should be very capable
to launch their own recruitment business
and achieve some of the success that
you've seen in other businesses what's
ended up being like the sweet spot that
you
found you want me the answer yeah yeah I
think three The Sweet Spot on on average
is probably three years three to four
years experience um they're still
they've built a solid desk between $500
to a million dollar um they're still on
the tools themselves they're still
passionate about Recruitment and they're
looking for that next step do I become a
billing manager and give up my career
and and only work in the sort of the top
7 to 10% of recruitment agencies that
are big enough to to Warrant a decent
billing manager and go through the
career of that or do I get to the point
where you know I don't do that and I
just you know enjoy the fruits of my
labor be the front end sales founder for
another couple of years and and build a
team so where being a billing manager in
your own business is obviously a lot
more fruitful than than being a billing
manager in a in a super large agency can
I add to that as well yeah yeah sure
I think a a really good uh addition to
what Dean's mentioned before is um
people that recognize that they're
strong individual
contributors sometimes recruiters have a
desire to become a billing manager which
is the worst job in recruitment hands
down and they don't realize it and so as
a billing manager you've got to manage
the team you get paid on the team's
performance but you uh you get very
little for the team's performance your
Billings drop you get paid on your own
Billings and it's just like this really
bad like combination of uh structure for
a billing manager that I find doesn't
doesn't work well and I don't know why
if I'm thinking of this wrong or I'm the
only guy that's worked this out but um
being a billing manager uh it sucks and
so but some people need to become a
billing manager to realize it sucks and
then go I would much prefer to be an
individual contributor focus on my own
desk bring in the money for myself earn
lots of money and you know that's what I
get a lot of value out of so those types
of people are perfect for ex- recruiter
some some recruiters enjoy like
mentoring and training and and putting
the spotlight on others and growing
other people which is still possible and
still good for obviously starting an
agency but um unless you've been a
billing manager before and you realize
it's probably not all cracked up to what
it's what you thought it would be then
uh generally ex recruit is you know
perfect for those types of people as
well that's that's the perfect person to
that realizes that yeah I need to go out
on my
own can I just give you my my take on
that because I'm I'm not I'm I
definitely it is definitely one of one
of the hardest jobs so my my actual
perspective on it is I completely agree
with what you're saying now those types
of people are also the exact types of
people that we work with to deliver
training on our platform and my actual
perspective on it is that yes it is one
of the most difficult jobs um in the
industry and uh one of the ones where
you could potentially not get a
financial reward in terms of what it's
worth compared to what he was getting as
an individual contributor but one of the
fundamental reasons why is that often
people aren't giving any support or help
on how to be a better manager or how to
be a better Coach you just expected to
look like you a 400 Grand biller now go
and help these two people that we've
just hired for you uh do the same and
like you're literally given no help on
how to do things like conduct good one
on ones how to ask not tell um how to
you know set people up for the week and
how do you hold people accountable how
do you have difficult conversations with
people how do you coach Like These
people aren't equipped to many of those
skills that that's what I find crazy
because these people as you know are
absolutely fundamental if you're
on a scale of business like they they
are the the future of your business and
that's how you're going to scale but
then there's some of the most
underinvested people in the
business it's it's lot sort of my take
on that as well with what with what you
said that's a fair point and that one
thing we've noticed is recruitment no
one invests in their recruiters like
it's I don't know they they sort of just
maybe that's why recruitment has such a
high turnover but it's not something
very common that you know maybe we we
see it happening more because now we're
focused we have been focused on it and
and upskilling actually business owners
but a lot of time in agency it's like
all right let's see who makes it get the
desk out and and start ripping in on the
phones so I think you're yeah I agree
with what you're saying maybe it's
disregarded training I I sense is very
ad hoc in recruitment it's like oh maybe
we should do some training and it's
there's no process behind it it's not
like okay let's just do a 90-day um you
know sales training for all the the
recruiters every 90 days yes we'll be
talking about things they already know
but uh I'm under the impression that you
know 80 % of everything that we learn is
just we just need to be reminded to do
the same thing we've already been taught
to do the other 20% the other 20% we
might actually learn something so
training is not because you don't know
what to do it's because you just need to
be reminded to do the basics which is
why your platform's so good and it's a
little bit more systemized where people
can just log on and if they've got a bit
of a routine where they go ah it's time
for me to get my training hit and just
refresh myself on the things that I that
I know but I might be forgetting to
implement and just keep to the basics
and keep doing the fundamental things
well then I think uh you're right
especially with billing managers if
you've got that training platform uh
either internally or externally through
a platform like yours then uh it'll
probably be much easier to be a billing
manager for
sure so D let me ask you like
um like I'm curious to get your thoughts
on this and what we're just talking
about so if I'm a business owner
listening to this and I want to do
everything that I can to keep my best
people the people that I know could be
my future competitors or like you know
future business owners what from the
conversations you've had what would be
the things that you'd have top of mind
that I could be doing or be really
intentional about that could really help
me retain my best people I know that's
not in your interest but I'm I'm
interested to get the reverse thing
because you're talking you're uncovering
the challenges and you know what these
people have and not everyone is is to
start their own business right but like
I think often times what like what
Blake's talking about like these people
that we promote progress can get
forgotten about even though yeah like
they're they're struggling they're
earning less money they're having to
deal with you know more challenges and
these things so if I'm a recruit
recruitment owner listening right now
what what should I be really leaning
into that could uh hopefully result in
keeping my my best performers well mate
I think um Blake's a perfect example of
this like him running the size of his
agency while we're doing X recruiter
every Wednesday we talk about we're on a
podcast talking about starting your own
agency there's the amount of followers
and content going out every single day
and he hasn't had one staff member even
want to sit down and and chat about
joining X recruiter so I think um just
being you know I I don't most of mate
I've got this saying maybe it's not even
my saying but Bad Bosses create more
businesses than entrepreneurs will ever
create so it's like being open honest
honest with your people knowing um
what's available to them obviously money
is important but only to it certain
point giving them Freedom giving them
investing in them knowing that there's
there's something for them you're not
just you know running a desk and and
that's all you'll ever be so just like
the basic fundamentals whether there's
businesses like x- recruiter or not um
you're still what happens if your
clients take your candidates recruitment
is a pretty low low paying based job
like the client clients are recruit for
bases are like 120 and you know that's
way above what a recruiter would get so
I think just yeah invest in your people
um obviously pay them well be there for
them keep them a part of your vision as
long as you're you've got to be the The
Guiding Light be the vision if you're
getting lackluster if you're losing
losing hope you're getting sloppy then
you're going to lose your team
regardless of if someone can get a
better Revenue share so yeah probably to
add to that as well um be person
interested in your recruiters you won't
lose a recruiter if you're dedicated to
get them achieving their personal goals
their professional goals are irrelevant
unless they're achieving their personal
goals like I've got recruiters like Lexi
she wants a new shed so I'm like what do
we need to do to get you a new shed
obviously it'll tie back into
recruitment billing saving more money
Josh he hasn't got a license I'm like
mate what the why haven't you got a
license yet you need to get a license I
will I will put you in my car and we'll
do the hours together to get you your
license mate so if you're invested
personally into the personal lives of
your recruiters um you will retain them
because they'll feel totally totally
obliged to support you in your journey
and what you're trying to achieve so um
I I think it's not actually about you
know Career Development and you know
commissions and all this kind of stuff
it's it's about understanding what their
personal goals are and if you're helping
them achieve their personal goals
they'll have a gratitude towards you far
beyond anyone to poach them or I've sat
down with my recruiters before and said
hey you know you'll earn more money with
ex recruiter if you just leave my agency
and go with ex recruiter we work out of
the same office yeah right it's exactly
the same and you know what they say mate
I love working here Blake I think you're
so awesome to me and you just help me
achieve my personal goals so I'd rather
just be here and get that and I'm like
all right sweet sounds good so the
biggest key takeaway and that's
obviously a really uh you know I'm very
blessed to have good staff as well but
um being invest personally in your
recruiters goes a really long
way no I really like that I think that
that's that's really helpful for
people the the personal bit I definitely
agree with that because you know if you
feel like you're moving forward in Life
or you're working towards something and
you're in an environment that is helping
you get
there yeah like even if you do leave
it's going to be on on good terms or
like just to keep going in that
direction right rather than for some of
the maybe frustrations and challenges
that that you guys are running into a
lot um another another question then
Dean I'm ke to get your uh thoughts on
this what I'd like you to sort of like
debunk the the my almost and what I mean
by that is I think often times maybe
people that aspire to have their own
business will hear their bosses or hear
you know Founders say on lightting Dean
it's way more difficult than you think
my friend it's a lot more harder than
you think it's not it's not easy this
you know it's not as easy as just set
starting up you know doing your own
Billings recruiting like what when
people say that what are the sort of
myth within that if you get what I mean
what are the things that maybe they're
overemphasizing or maybe AR as true as
their sort of make out because I do
think often
times people over EG that a
bit yeah yeah definitely sometimes um
well I suppose with X recruiter it's
literally the same environment as if you
would be working at a normal agency so
everything gets taken care of um the
hardest part would be having to upscu in
multiple different areas so you know
you're you're a successful recruiter you
only do one thing you find clients and
candidates build relationships when you
become a business owner you've got to
learn about tax you've got to learn
about submissions you've got to learn
about websites what's built on what CRM
what providers are you getting a good
rate uh you know we've experienced a lot
of expert Consultants come in and and
create a problem for you then charge you
for it so like that is um those
little things that people can take you
advantage of um the lack of resources
just the unknown mate like that's
probably the hardest part you you
recruitment was hard when you first took
your first job because it was all
unknown and then getting into business
it's all unknown like am I getting a
good deal am I getting the best
accountant am I getting the best partner
for this best partner for that so I
think the the hardest part to anything
is is unknown like you know we can go 5
years in business and build year on year
um but like what's it look like you know
getting scaling to a team at 20 and all
that type of stuff so I think for me
it's just a I don't know what do you
reckon unknown would be the
biggest yeah just thinking about your
question again so so your myth well like
is there a myth or is are we going to
bust a myth to say you know your boss
tells you oh mate you couldn't start
your own agency it's too hard and you
know is it really is is that kind of
your question yeah yeah yeah because I
think sometimes that that can be like
over EG so I understand I understand
what de is saying there are a lot of
unknowns and you got to learn about so
many other like new things but I think
sometimes I feel like it can be like
overemphasized that that's what I was
just curious to get your take on on
maybe that isn't you know I'm not trying
to get you to discredit the service that
that you provide but I I do think
sometimes it can be overemphasized is is
like my honest is my honest thought
well your boss can't say that anymore
because of ex- recruiter so we have
bustered that my but if if you don't
have access to X recruiter I mean it's
like anything like yeah it's it has its
challenges but like starting an agency
it isn't complicated like it's not
rocket science I'm sure if you've been
able to figure out Recruitment and the
the nuances and and the the little like
tricks and tips that you've applied in
recruitment if you just apply that
proactive perseverance type of nature to
starting your business you'll be able to
do it um so you know yeah I I totally
agree with you it's not it's not as hard
as everyone says it is but it's kind of
but it is harder than you think it will
be so there's a middle if you looked at
each if you looked at each part of the
process like going to gym is easy right
just do more bicep curls do more squats
eat healthy but then actually um
actually actually doing it and executing
it's a different thing because you got
to deal with feelings you got to deal
with people's opinions that's probably
the stuff that's that's harder to it all
yeah sure you can go on a government
website or speak to an accountant open a
business you can go and build your own
website you can go and speak to you know
if you want to use LinkedIn or find a
CRM or use seek indeed whatever you
start you know you can break it all down
it's um and work it out but it's just
the um yeah I I think people way over
complicated and once you do like all
those stages are very simple but when
you're you've got Financial pressures
you're not billing your mates will think
it's more of the psychology it's also
the time no I get it it's also the time
right
that's yeah like the time the time you
could lose to all that stuff which is
away from the core activity that Blake
has said that's going to help you you
know get closer to getting you know your
invoices paid and getting invoices out
so like I do get it I just think um yeah
sometimes it can be uh over
overemphasized um but I do I think you
know back
to retaining people I think the best
recruitment
companies also in for their leadership
team I think sometimes what they miss is
they don't actually really help Blake
the director develop his commercial
Acumen like I think often times people
can be in that leadership seat and they
don't know how the business makes money
so they think that the numbers on the
board is them making money but they
don't know that they don't get paid for
60 days and they don't know how that
then goes to gross profit and how they
generate net fee income and how that
affects the EIT D of the business like I
think that that's also something that's
often missed is if you're just treating
people to be recruiters and just worry
about those basic metrics rather than
help them develop their understanding of
p&l how they actually make money as a
business how they what levers they can
pull to make more um uh money in these
things I think that's often overlooked
and can also help you retain your best
people if they think if they feel like
they're also developing their commercial
and and business understanding because
that can help them you know maybe start
their own business at some point but I
think that's also often over a
look
100% um so where so you just hit the hit
the year
mark got some uh got some awards under
your
belt where um where where we where we
where we heading then boys where where
are we going what what are some of the
big objectives we're going to the moon
going on the moon have you seen our
astronaut suits when we get you over
here for in person podcast we'll give
you one yeah 100% yeah know that that
look Mega so like yeah talk talk to me
about you know you just hit the Em which
is
awesome like where where we going where
we
heading yeah we'll let BL have go he
likes tell come on mate you go you
tell go bab you have a go okay so so
we've got a a a goal that we want to
change the lives of 100 a mission it's
our mission it's not our mission cuz
we'll do our mission by 20 25 then we
got to what get a new Mission this is
just our goal shortterm goal all right
back to me okay so Okay so we've got
like we've got a goal um that we want to
change the lives of 100 recruiters by
January
2025 so short term um what's that like
15 16 months we're going to help launch
100 recruitment agencies so soon to work
with eight more people by then yeah
exactly probably a little bit L yeah
we're what are we at the moment like 23
24 at the moment so pretty much Mar 80
um so that's kind of our short-term goal
once we hit 100 I think we want to uh
officially go to the UK and the US so
we're already speaking to UK Partners us
partners that are interested in starting
up a division in the UK and the us but
um short term yeah 100 100 lives changed
is what we're calling it um and helping
100 recruiters start their own agency we
eventually do want to Branch out so to
speak and help micro agencies
be better placed for systems processes
technology that kind of stuff so I think
there's a really big market for existing
agency owners with one to three staff
that probably um are working their ass
off and not making much money if they
just had a bit more support they could
probably do the things that they're good
at so uh we definitely want to uh start
going a little bit harder with our
message to market around are you a small
agency owner do you want to earn more
money do you want a bit more freedom
time flexibility in your life um let us
handle all the back off of stuff and
we'll make you look pretty and make you
more
money love that deely anything to
add no I think that um that sums it up
it's um yeah it's an exciting journey I
know you you have yeah you have
Ambitions and stuff but sometimes you're
I don't know saying it out loud but he
feels Silly by saying our goals out loud
sometimes why yeah so sometimes you got
to give him a bit of a Raz up that's why
I give him a little nudge from time to
time I don't know if you're going to
edit that
puppy no I I can definitely relate to
that but I think I'm just too right like
I'm what I'm watching um I definitely
recommend it it's called um a series
called uh we crashed which is about the
story of we work and the guy that
started it honestly this guy is like
he's personally I feel like he's over
indexed the way of like he's basically
walking into um you know uh business
meetings saying that we're going to be a
multi-billion company and they haven't
even got like one office space yet yes
but like sometimes you need that energy
right oh we've got that energy yeah yeah
we've got that energy I I get what you
mean though I know sometimes why you
might be reluctant to sort of you know
really pump your chest and say this is
what we're doing I get that because
sometimes I feel like that but I think
it's important oh okay well be open no
Dean's a little bit more reserved he's
trying to be a little bit humble on the
podcast but if you talk to him in real
life he's like we're getting a thousand
agencies baby let's go building a $100
million company um in 5 years but yeah
yeah there we go so starting to Envision
that but yeah the goal is to yeah
obviously build aund million company
Empower thousands of recruiters um
across the world to to work for
themselves and and you know there's a
great great story of Andrew Banks and um
and Morgan morg Bank Morgan Banks
obviously the first billion dollar
company sold out of Australia
recruitment agency so you know we just
ET our name in history in in recruitment
reimagine
it love it boys well like ke keep doing
what you're doing I think um you know
what what you're offering is is very
much needed for the the right type of
people right so I think um for the right
type of people this is going to like
like genuinely you know give them the
opportunity to change their lives which
would be really difficult to achieve or
just a lot more harder to do um without
the type of service and support that you
provide so yeah keep keep doing what
you're doing boys and thank you so much
for for joining me on the Pod no worries
and I think that's one of the biggest
just quickly to to add to that the
actual feel-good moments whether it
could be you know a single mom getting
into business for the first time
inspiring her two young kids or you know
a 25 year-old realizing their potential
early on that compounding effect of what
could happen in the future that's like
those types of stuff it just you know
that's what gets you so G up and excited
um so mate really appreciate you letting
us share our little
story love it boys thanks for joining me
thank you thanks mate